金ちゃん外れ社長ですかほんじゃああー目社長です
じゃあ皆さんどうですかよりはくる saas 版季節ですね
ね
今年もねあのでいよいよ大すぐ2013年も終わりということで
未明さんからの原発択ゲームが
すごい変種どうすごいと思います a 4君から上がってきたのでちょっと覚えて
いこうと思います
ソース一番良かったことは何ですか
今年は何ですかね
留学に聞いたことですね従業員することによって世界中に友達ができたのと
何ですかねぇ
やっぱいろんな人が世界に入れなって思ったのと
あったねー
例えば英語英語でしょ
英語ができたらもう
なんでもないです英語が勉強できたらすごいいろんな人と会話ができるようになるので
英語がそのらしさを学びました
やっぱり留学はお金が高いんじゃことに
簡単に行けるもんじゃないと思っている留学に踏み出すまでが
にベストしてこい
ね何とかしようと思ったんですけど
アカナかそんなん一人で出せるような額じゃなかったんで本当に
まずは親に感謝しています
妄想留学や頑張ります今年一番はなかったことは何ですか
年はそうですねー
はなかったことないよって
のことかうん
やっぱん
いやでも治った勝った悪かったことん
合わないんだよ
の上だと思う
ん
あそうだペアパルド呼ばれるわけだ
ソース万円でタイガー
木原位になったところですことですね日本帰ってもう
ホットでこう騒げるようなねボーアシステムパック3ので大家さんがいないよ
なって探していこうと思います
5000一番好きだったゲームアニメアプリ
保持一番好きだったゲームアニメアプリ曲などを教えてください
ゲームはですね
ゲームしだけだったんですよアニメなんですけどシュタインズゲートですなんとか
狂四郎金方向性なんですけどちょっとイカレてて絞めたことはマッドサイエンティスト
と思ってて
タイムマシーンをつくれず米兵といったなぁ本当にできるって話です
やっぱりアンだろう albany ちゃんですねキャラを開きました
ok
渠渠
まぁこんな書買ったからなぁ
何でしょ
あえてなら浜崎あゆみのシーズンですね
どうし買って良かったものを3つ紹介してください
一つ前
中に使った変わってるね
イギリスにいるから何か買いたいものもないし勝ってどうかをするわけでもないんで
うちの特にないです新年の抱負
言わせていただきます
北
3月ぐらいに日本に帰るんですけど
来年は
俺の時代にします
漢字なんてちょっと今ねー留学州でねー
そんなねー
今どう the door 日からおおなんと言えばいい
尾鷲れないんですけどあーん
月にまだ俺は全然本気だしねーからのまだ見いだせないみたいな引き出してねーから
10年
ちょっともうねさが続くレースがちょっとしていた
プレイ時はもう間ここって使うんだ食べてる人
デラックス家と芦屋さんですじゃあ